je suis né dans le 93 à montreuil dans
une famille bretonne de parents qui
travaillait dans le service public et
une mère professeur dans l'éducation
nationale
donc les études dans ma famille c'était
quelque chose de très important donc à
force d'efforts et d'encouragement
famille où j'ai fait un parcours
scolaire dans des établissements
prestigieux
j'étais à louis-le-grand j'ai fait mes
classes préparatoires dans cet
établissement et ensuite j'ai intégré
l'essec a 19 ans et pour poursuivre sur
cette lancée quand je suis arrivé à
l'essec
ga je suis allé dans la junior
entreprise et j'étais devenue présidente
d'un g comme une junior entreprise
jumelée avec supélec et quand on a fait
genre de parcours la voie royale c'est
la banque d'affaires dont je me suis
retrouvé dans des salles de marchés à
londres en 1993 rajeunit pas et
néanmoins je me suis retrouvé dans cette
salle et l'atterrissage était assez
difficile pour moi ce que j'étais
habitué à faire un peu ce que je voulais
a mené ma barque dans ma junior
entreprise est donc cet environnement
fait de normes de règles de beaucoup
beaucoup de travail intense a créé chez
moi une forme un petit peu de rébellion
j'ai pas très bien vécu la hiérarchie et
le respect de tous les gens avec
lesquels je travaillais dans ce monde là
est donc dix-huit mois après mon entrée
dans la bande à faire et c'est passé un
événement décisif et distant yens
quasiment en tous les cas salutaire est
quasiment le plus positif de ma vie
professionnelle j'ai été licencié lire
et mise à la porte à l'américaine avec
un petit carton vite dehors je suis
jamais retourné après et là je me suis
posé pour la première fois de ma vie
véritablement des questions pour la
première fois véritablement je me suis
dit est ce que je suis dans le bon
endroit est ce que j'ai fait les bonnes
études est ce que la bande à faire c'est
pour moi est ce que la finance c'est là
où je veux travailler est ce que ça va
me rendre heureuse dont j'ai beaucoup
des primés ça a été un quand même un
choc assez important j'étais pas
prédestiné à être licenciés surtout
aussi vite et
du coup j'ai rencontré plein de
personnes différentes qui vont parler de
leur vie de leur carrière l'univers des
possibles étaient était très ouvert et
j'ai pris la décision importante de
retourner dans la banque d'affaires
j'y suis retourné mais cette fois ci
complètement différemment j'ai su
retourner en me disant je vais y rester
dix ans je vais m'acheter ma liberté je
vais faire des économies et puis après
je ferai ce que je veux je ferai tout et
n'importe quoi vraiment ma vie sera très
ouverte à partir de ce moment là donc
j'ai passé les 80 qui restait pour
arriver à 10 ans j'ai pas vraiment
compter les années mais je trouve qu'à
ce moment là une crise personnelle
familiale professionnelle tout est
arrivé en même temps m'est tombé dessus
et là j'ai peut-être vécu sans trop le
savoir une petite forme de dépression je
suis allé me ressourcer en thaïlande
méditez avait des moines bouddhistes et
j'en suis revenu zen je savais à ce
moment là avec toutes ces questions qui
m'avait agité une nouvelle fois dans ma
vie que j'allais faire autre chose cet
autre chose resté assez vague mais il
était fondamentalement différent de ce
que j'avais pu faire avant quelques sons
est question de me suis posée au moment
de ce changement de vie changement de
métier je savais je voulais du
changement je voulais plusieurs vies -
changement ne me fait pas peur il a
plutôt tendance à m'exciter eu aucune
résistance au changement et j'ai un gros
appétit pour le risque le risque à la
fois le risque de se mettre en risque
mais aussi le risque physique me fais
pas non plus particulièrement peur je
suis très curieuse des autres ça me
changeait un petit peu de mes collègues
de la banque d'affaires j'avais une
envie d' aventure d'aller d'aller un peu
mangé le monde et je me suis beaucoup
penché sur mon épanouissement personnel
je les regardais en moins j'ai pas
regardé à l'extérieur je suis aller
creuser pour aller chercher au fond moi
même ce qui allait me rendre heureuse et
je suis parti ça c'est assez à la mode
en ce moment je suis parti à la quête du
sens et ce sens je les je me suis dit
allez peut-être le trouver dans un
univers radicalement différent de la
banque d'affaires américaine français
j'ai fait les deux et je me suis dit je
vais j'aimerais je suis vraiment motivé
pour partir en mission humanitaire
mais c'est vraiment à 180° de
de la banque d'affairé pourtant il ya
des points communs alors la bande à
faire c'est l'argent c'est le virtuel
c'est pour moi une forme de désunissent
déshumanisation au sens où les rapports
humains ne sont pas au coeur du métier
c'est une des collections on vit quand
même dans une bulle de verre dans un
univers très protégée et en ce moment ça
a même tendance à basculer dans plus de
spéculation que l'économie réelle
l'humanitaire c'est le risque physique
c'est la mise en danger des personnes on
se met en danger en partant en mission
c'est l'univers de l'émotionnel on
inverse de la banque d'affaires on n'est
pas dans du rationnel on est dans
l'engagement autour d'une cause
on est dans la contribution à la société
et il ya une très forte culture des
humanitaires auxquelles forcément moi
j'étais un petit peu différente un
élément étranger à ce monde mais
pourtant ils ont des points communs où
je pouvais tout de même apporter quelque
chose
des méthodes de travail très
professionnel humanitaire c'est pas le
métier romantique depuis longtemps c'est
maintenant très cadré avec des gestions
des ressources humaines ou financières
on parle d'un pâté de retour sur
investissement dans l'humanitaire on va
effectivement chercher quand on investit
un euro
comme on le disait tout à l'heure qu'est
ce que je vais effectivement faire avec
cet argent c'est multidisciplines
disciplinaires dans la banque d'affaires
j'avais des clients qui étaient des
sociétés de tous les univers et dans
l'humanitaire j'interagis avec des
nutritionnistes des infirmières des
hydrauliciens des agronomes et des
logisticiens et encore les deux autres
représentations sociales ambiguë enfin
surtout aujourd'hui moi à l'époque
enchères vraiment d'affaires ce qui est
quelque chose qu'il fallait faire
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être un petit peu
moins 7 6 néanmoins la représentation
sociale de l'humanitaire est aussi un
peu complexe c'est les roues du 21e
siècle ceux qui vont changer le monde et
sauver des vies et tous les deux ont des
représentations sociales à ces fausses
et croyez moi dans les deux il y à
d'énormes enjeux de pouvoir ce sera
peut-être l'objet d'une autre conférence
et me voilà partie au soudan au darfour
en plein conflit de guerre civile dont
c'était un baptême du feu et j'ai vécu
une mission une mission humanitaire dans
un pays où il ya la charia ou c'est un
climat assez hostile en tous les cas moi
issu de france j'ai eu du mal à m'y
habituer et en matière d' aventure de
rencontre avec l'autre si différent de
moi cgt
très largement récompensé dans cette
aventure j'y ai passé un an j étais
confrontés à des réalités difficiles
entendre lui contre la faim on rencontre
des enfants qui souffrent de la faim et
on se sent fondamentalement utile je me
suis sentie pour la première fois sans
doute de ma vie à ma place
j'étais pourtant dans un bureau qui
faisait très certainement 5 mètres
carrés qui tombe est complètement en
ruines et j'avais des collègues de
travail qui ne ressemblait pas du tout à
ce que j'avais pu rencontrer dans la
banque d'affaires
et c'est cette vie m'a amené à une
réflexion très simple je pense que
masselot l'avait fait avant moi mais ça
a fait reculer et je me suis dit que
j'avais sans doute cherché pendant
longtemps le confort matériel et la
reconnaissance sociale je suis allé
chercher un bon salaire je suis allé
chercher un métier qui satisfaisait ma
famille qui satisfaisait mes amis qui
avaient une bonne reconnaissance sociale
je pouvais dire j'étais vice président
jp morgan en laissant peut-être de côté
cet épanouissement personnel qu'est ce
que je cherche pour moi qu'est ce qui me
rend heureuse - pas vis-à-vis des autres
vis-à-vis de moi-même pour chercher
finalement le bonheur et ce bonheur dans
la société française on peut pas dire
que ce soir tout à fait le cas
nous sommes 64e sur 65 pays des plus
pessimistes du monde il y à un pays qui
nous fait le plaisir d'être dernier mais
sinon quand même on est assez pessimiste
et à quelques années on était même plus
pessimiste hui les irakiens ou que les
afghans nous sommes un pays qui ne
votent plus qu'il ne croit pas en la
démocratie qui dans lequel on voit de
plus en plus d'actes racistes vous
l'avez sans doute noté et dans lequel
les inégalités sociales augmentent moins
que dans le monde mais néanmoins à une
vitesse importante et pour moi cette
france là ce n'est pas seulement la
crise qu'il a créée pour moi c'est notre
modèle de société qui peut être est à
repenser comment repenser un modèle de
société qui est fondée sur une société
de consommation avec la croissance comme
fondement des cas plus de croissance on
est en panne à peu près dans tous les
niveaux
une entreprise qui vise le profit c'est
dans sa nature c'est dans son adn
devaient rechercher le profit une
éducation qui vous donne les clés pour
avoir un médecin
gagner un salaire peut-être vous parle
pas nécessairement tous les jours de
votre épanouissement personnel et de
votre envie justice sociale qui est
fondée sur les passions des richesses
matérielles et une fiscalité et une
économie mondiale qui tourne autour de
choses très importantes qui est un peu
le graal c'est la richesse matérielle
visiblement plus on est riche plus on
est heureux il nous faut je ne sais pas
combien d'iphone ou de voitures ou de
maisons mais la croissance l'entreprise
et tout
tous ces éléments de société convergent
fortement peut-être pas uniquement mais
assez fortement vers un paradigme de
richesses matérielles et moi je souhaite
vous proposer de révolutionner non pas
avec des idées mais peut-être une seule
idée pourquoi ne pas avoir une société
qui tend vers le bonheur de tous et de
chacun de tous et de chacun il ne s'agit
pas ici que la société vous rendre
heureux non il faut que la société vous
donne les moyens d'aller dans votre
propre quête votre quête de sens et
votre quête de bonheur ne s'agit pas non
plus de dire que je vais être heureux et
ça suffit c'est le bonheur de tous et de
chacun il ya le droit que la société
peut vous donner d'accéder à votre
bonheur quel qu'il soit pour certains ce
sera d'être riche pour d'autres ce sera
de travailler de rester dans une
province une région et qu'il aime
beaucoup et mémé le devoir qui va avec
et de contribuer aussi au bonheur des
autres alors ça a l'air très simple mais
moi qui ai fait quand même une école de
commerce je vais vous parler un petit
peu de comment ça se décline parce que
c'est pas juste une utopie réaliste ou
peut-être que si je ne sais pas ça
voudrait dire remettre un petit peu en
en cause ou en tout cas en débat cette
société de consommation qui nous pousse
pas d'été type de marketing à acheter
c'est peut-être fondé l'entreprise sur
le modèle de l'entreprise sociale
solidaire et j'ajouterais
environnementale peut-être que la seule
entreprise qui vaille le coup pour
fonder cette société où nous serions
peut-être tous un petit peu plus heureux
ce serait cette entreprise là il
faudrait inventer un modèle de
croissance faible après tout pourquoi
toujours faire croître les richesses
nous sommes le 65e pays en termes de
démographie est en train de se poser la
question de savoir si on est cinquièmes
ou sixièmes pays en richesse est il
vraiment nécessaire d'être le pays le
plus riche moi je souhaite aux
brésiliens aux indiens ou chinois qui
sont bien
plus nombreux nous d'être aussi riche
l'économie mondiale pourrait être
l'économie du partage les jeunes nous
montre le chemin internet en août le
chemin il ya aujourd'hui un principe ou
au delà d'un certain nombre de pièces
tout ça aurait un coût zéro donc cette
économie ne partage est déjà en marche
la justice sociale pour être fondée non
pas sur l'égalité mais sur l'équité
je pense qu'il faudrait repenser ce
concept la fiscalité pourrait parler non
pas de schiste et défiscalisées des
revenus mais une contribution sociale et
solidaire et l'éducation elle
revaloriserait le travail manuel ou
créerait d'autres liens avec
l'entreprise tout ça pour tendre vers
leur bonheur de tous et de chacun et je
finirai en vous disant vous allez
peut-être venir tout ça et est
impossible trop difficile impossible à
réaliser
et je vous dirais que quand je regarde
ces femmes qui célèbre un mariage dans
le camp de déplacés davo choc au darfour
en pleine guerre civile
oui décidément tout est possible merci